on march 9 valorent player and
ex-overwatch pro
jay sinatra wan was accused of sexual
assault
and sexual misconduct by his
ex-girlfriend he's since been suspended
from
sentinel's valorant roster while an
investigation is carried out
and will be unable to play in this
weekend's valorent masters event
sinatra denies these allegations here's
the whole story
before i begin i'd like to warn anybody
watching right now
that there are some pretty explicit
descriptions of sexual assault
in this video so if that's something
you'd like to avoid i just want to give
you a warning to click off now
before i continue so this story started
just prior to 11 p.m eastern time on
march 9th
cleo hernandez sinatra's ex-girlfriend
published a tweet with the caption
my last relationship along with an
attached document titled
jay now this document is nine pages it's
very thorough
extremely graphic and includes text
messages discord conversations and an
audio clip
all meant to reinforce hernandez's
allegations for the purposes of this
video
i obviously can't review the entire
thing but here's a breakdown of what's
being alleged
hernandez says that she and sinatra
dated for nine months
she alleges that over the course of that
time he made unwanted sexual advances
after she told him not to she felt like
saying no to sex was
never an option he would continue to
have sex with her after she told him to
stop and was in pain
he acted manipulatively and guilted her
into having sex
after she said no he was emotionally
abusive he would check her location
using his iphone
and if it didn't match where she said
she was he would accuse her of cheating
and that she lived in constant fear of
him hernandez also began the document by
alleging that sinatra claimed
that she threatened to kill herself if
he broke up with her she said that this
isn't true and that she broke up with
him from the beginning of the document
hernandez alleges that this pattern of
behavior
started very early on in their
relationship she writes quote
the first time we ever slept together i
told him i wasn't on birth control and
he could not finish in me
he did it anyways without my consent end
quote she also said that she got an iud
because sinatra refused to use a condom
and it ended up making sex very painful
for her and she says that sinatra didn't
care
quote i would say it hurt and i wanted
to stop and he'd say
no no i'm so close as much as it hurt i
learned that he didn't mind hurting me
and had no problem with leaving me
crying in the bathroom while he slept
she went on to say quote he knew it hurt
badly enough for me to go to the doctor
and still disregarded my pain he can't
try and say that he just didn't know
he knew end quote also included in the
document
are imessage conversations that appear
to show sinatra asking her
if she was cheating on him referencing
her location
imessa's conversations that appear to
show sinatra criticizing her for
tweeting about another overwatch league
team
that he wasn't on and discord
conversations dated november 23rd
2019 that appear to show hernandez
talking to someone about being scared of
sinatra
and worrying that he was using her for
sex finally there is also a link to an
audio clip in the document that cleo
says is taken from a video of the two
having sex
in the clip sinatra appears to be asking
for them to continue having sex
while she's denying his advances
repeatedly throughout the document cleo
describes being afraid in the
relationship
she also describes him acting
possessively and needing to know where
she was at all times
she also says that he used yelling as a
way to win arguments
quote he learned that he would yell at
me and i would apologize even if i
wasn't in the wrong
and he used that pretty frequently if i
ever wanted to bring up something i
thought he was doing wrong he would turn
it around
and make it something i was doing wrong
and make me apologize
for even suggesting he was doing
anything incorrectly
i just learned not to say he was doing
anything wrong just easier than arguing
with a narcissist
sinatra was set to compete in the first
major event of the valerant champions
tour
that's happening this weekend masters
one so the next day
on wednesday march 10th both the vct
and sentinels tweeted that they were
aware of the situation
and with an investigation looming
sinatra would not be allowed to play in
masters this weekend
here's sentinel's statement we are aware
of the current situation regarding j
sinatra juan and have launched an
investigation internally
while the investigation is pending he is
suspended from the team
we will provide a further update once
the investigation has concluded
end quote later on wednesday night
sinatra responded to hernandez's
allegations on twitter
with a twitlonger titled update quote it
is clear from cleo's recent post that
she recalls our relationship differently
than i do
what we do agree on is that it was
unhealthy for both of us
i apologize to cleo and regret how
things ended but i never assaulted her
in any way i am fully cooperating with
the investigations and providing the
full audio and video clips cleo
referenced in her post
end quote after his statement went live
hernandez responded
quote tweeting him and criticizing him
for not reaching out to her personally
since his relationship with hernandez
sinatra has switched esports from
overwatch to valorant
but the events described in her
allegations would have happened while he
was a member of the san francisco shock
in the overwatch league the shock also
tweeted out a statement the overwatch
league itself took
action on wednesday night offering
support and a refund for sinatra's
overwatch league mvp skin
and of course in addition to the
statements coming from sinatra's current
and former orgs
there were messages of support for
hernandez from across the esports
community
including from popular streamer myth who
actually addressed the situation
directly on stream and supported the
vct's decision
to suspend sinatra i've come to the
conclusion that like
if somebody says no or stop in any tone
like here's what my initial reaction my
initial reaction would
one stop and then be like
wait wait is everything okay
like my reaction wouldn't be to like
keep and go and you know what i mean
like that is
that is that is that is not it dude
it's just not it with that said there
was one early dissenting voice
before sinatra's statement former
overwatch pro and streamer defran
defran rather and elegantly urged people
to wait for sinatra's side of the story
before
coming to conclusions which many on
twitter immediately criticized
myth included i i get what he's saying
here
but like he did not say it in the right
way
at all just because i'm waiting for the
whole story
doesn't mean that i'm not going to
believe what the victim has to say yet
does that mean disregard yeah you know
does that mean does that make sense
and i think i think that's the issue
with some of these people that
that makes statements like they're
waiting for the whole story
but they they say that the [ __ ] that
she's typed isn't
true because they don't have the whole
story
when that's just not valid like you
can't they can't say that
unfortunately sexual assault and sexual
misconduct allegations are not foreign
to the esports space
especially over the course of the last
year if you remember back in july
we covered the movement of hundreds of
allegations that were levied against
personalities in the gaming
esports and streaming world and while
that was the beginning
since then stories have continued to be
shared months later
after all of the back and forth about
the allegations against sinatra on
wednesday
on thursday march 11th sentinels
announced that they would be bringing in
former cloud9 valorant player tens as
sinatra's replacement for masters this
weekend
following that announcement the vct na
account released this statement
regarding the addition of tens to their
roster
sentinels requested an exception to the
roster lock period to add a substitute
to their roster
in light of the circumstances the
exception was granted
per rule 2.3 of the global competition
policy
players may not play for or contract
with more than one team at a time
to comply with this rule sentinels have
acquired all rights to tens
tens will no longer represent cloud9
from this announcement it seems like
tens will not only be standing in for
sentinels but in order to do so
they had to actually acquire the rights
to have him play for them
from cloud9 now the results of the
investigation
into these allegations made against
sinatra are obviously still ongoing
we're following the situation closely
and we'll be sure to have an update once
we know more
[Music]
you